on arrive sur la zone de largage appel
vous vous êtes bien amusé samedi soir
les copains de mon corps tête de ragtime
sont morts alors le samedi en général je
sors plus si vous demandez à kristen aux
statistiques de sortir avec vous elle
acceptera c'est sûr c'est pour ça que je
le demande pas trop timide autres lâche
donc occuper
il avait un parachute non
what parachute 1
j'ai intégré le fil pour défendre les
populations cape town pour construire un
monde meilleur il faut parfois détruire
l'ancien
et on se fait des ennemis
êtes vous prêt à montrer au monde votre
vrai visage
regardez dehors
vous connaissez les règles du jeu
le désordre de guerre
il n'ya qu'un pas à faire
nous allons le réaliser beaucoup de
menaces avant qu'elles soient mises à
exécution
je croyais que la punition neveu n'est
qu'après le crime
nous ne croyons pas un monde idéal nous
le prenons comme hiver ça ce n'est pas
la liberté c'est la terreur
gardez les deux yeux qian ouvert avant
quand démarre quelqu'un va-t-il renoncer
vous avez travaillé pour le bien de
l'humanité
vous avez forgée ce siècle
ce que j'attends de vous encore une fois
à nous de jouer il est temps